so basically what i do is i
pick like 15 women from instagram all in
different states from united states
different cities and i fly them all out
and i move them into my house and their
incentive
to come is just to be with you or you
know it's the platform
you know so you're not paying these
women no no they just get the they get
you know you get to come stay here you
get some exposure yeah you get the
exposure you get to stay here
everything's free like we
dick
no
so you're not [ __ ] any other women oh
man it's it's it's not a dating show
it's not blue girls i'm not i'm just
hosting
so i'm the type of person but they live
with you
well i don't live there i got two houses
oh so you do have multiple cribs okay uh
i gotta i said like i got a house where
i just do [ __ ] at parties and yeah and
then i got my home where you lay your
head exactly yeah so this is my house
not my home so
i move them all in
um and just get the drama i guess you
know i'm the host so i just come in and
make them a little bit more maybe
competitive or more
[Music]
of how are they feeling
so
the uh one girl wins each season no
there's no winner there's no winner um
it's just more or less like a
if you make it to the end
it kind of like tied in type thing kind
of like you know officially a blue girl
and they get tattoos
it sounds like there's real no incentive
for these girls to come on the show it's
like you can come
you can leave with a tattoo and some
clout but really that's about it
well yeah i mean it's what you do with
it you know like
i don't know like they all come for
their own reasons right one might want
to be a rapper
so the exposure for her is
you get you get some
you know you might get a feature or
something yeah
[ __ ] you might meet somebody because we
do studio sessions all the time we go
out you
half these girls never even been to l.a
bro so like i said i'm bringing them
from baltimore florida alabama
jesus